The joe rogan experience.
What can we get to the flag bill those first cause we might forget.
Yes.
Okay.
Flying Dildos.
Here we go.
So I called Joe,
this is what you said.
You Go,
we were just talking about this and you're like,
yeah,
you got so many crazy stories that have happened to you and it and,
and,
but I never think that,
I think there are just things in my life.
I think it's my ability,
the way I see something happen is different than a way everyone else sees it
happen.
You know,
I see the,
the little thing that,
that registers in me,
I go all,
that's my thing.
You know,
and it lights up for me where my wife just glazes over it and it's come to light
in this podcast more than anything.
The machine,
I mean,
the way I've told the story to fucking a million people,
but then when I told him to do something lit up and I went,
oh,
that is a good story,
right?
The fucking fighting a bear.
The fuck everything.
I'm getting mauled by a bull,
Tracy Morgan,
everything's lights up.
So then I'm talking on the phone today.
I call you,
Hey,
can you divide and you go.
I said,
I'm on the phone with Delta,
American Airlines trying to get upgraded.
Your like,
where you going?
I said,
Amsterdam.
He said,
I've never been there.
I said,
oh,
whatever you do,
do you ever go there?
Don't go see flying dildos.
True Story.
Right.
So,
so I'm fucking like 22.
I'm an NF to Amsterdam where with like five friends and there and of course we
do the rounds in Amsterdam and get fucking lit up.
Heineken factory,
hedgehogs,
I think even maybe mushrooms.
We walked by this live sex show and it says on the billboard gone girl,
girl on girl oral sex,
uh,
this,
this and then the last one is flying dildos.
Come see flying dildos.
Since all Mike fucking,
I tell everyone we're seeing fine dildos.
I want to see fucking flying deal does.
That to me is a showstopper.
That is something that I will buy tickets for everyone for us.
Why buy us all tickets?
We go in to see a live sex show.
Have you ever seen one?
No.
It's basically like,
like half a boxing ring.
So it's like you walk in and it's stadium seating and then half a boxing ring
where they just without the ropes and they just,
everything happens right there.
They just fuck it.
Just fuck.
Oh and our dudes beating off and the audience,
are you allowed to wear lipstick?
No.
Dudes aren't beating off in the audience.
No,
it's a Chi.
It is kind of creepy now that you say that because I don't know what we were
supposed to do,
but there was like 20 people in there,
but we sat in that.
Yeah,
I guess maybe you should have been what?
We didn't and we ruined it for everyone.
Um,
so we sit down and they're like,
they come out and they're like,
the first is um,
girl on girl.
This is just how ut important,
right?
So two girls come out and they're like,
they go to eat and just taken two girls come out and start going flying dildos,
flying duplos and they're like,
no,
we're not playing dildos.
I go,
ah,
now do any guys are like,
well,
I want to see flying dildos too.
So they do their thing,
they leave.
A girl comes out by herself,
masturbation,
and I go flying dildos and she goes,
no,
I'm not flying dildos.
I fucking,
everyone that came to the stage,
I just yelled flying dildos.
How many people came to this day and like nine acts,
nine acts come to the stage.
How about get along is each one doing,
I'm five minutes from fucking masturbating and then eating each other out and
then blowing a dude and then the guy fucks the girl that's like the headliner,
right?
Like,
and we get to the guy fucking the girl and I'm like,
you better be fucking flying dildos.
And the guys like,
we're not fling dildos.
Okay,
stop with the fucking playing dildos.
And I'm like,
oh my book.
The whole time.
They're fucking why they're fucking them.
Yeah.
Now we've got 20 dudes and they're all on my team because no fucking hammer.
And I'm like,
[inaudible] was right.
So then all of a sudden I have the duty fog.
A lady comes out with a doctor's,
a little brief Kagan and the doctor's thing bag and just walks up on stage.
I go,
you better be fucking fine Dylan.
He goes,
ladies and gentlemen,
I am flying belows and the fucking place goes nuts.
Like fucking right out of the military guy when he goes,
I'm going to need and I'm going to need someone from the audience.
And everyone's like,
fuck,
I'm fucking,
I am definitely going up there.
Of course he did.
So I get up,
I'm not going up there and everyone's turning five dildos,
build those.
I got my hands up and she goes,
okay,
okay.
Hands behind back.
And I put my hands behind my back and she handcuffs me and everyone's like
flying.
Like everyone's going fucking nuts.
She dropped my pants,
cuts my shirts with the scissors,
throws me on the back,
puts a dildo on my mouth and just fucks it and then stands up.
She goes,
that was flying builders and she leaves me with a Dildo on my mouth naked.
Everyone's taking pictures like fucking step right up to the for like I had
handcuffs on,
I couldn't fuck move and just snap,
snap,
snap.
And I'm just like,
somebody help me get the devil out of my mouth.
It was a fucking nightmare.
So we have a photo of this.
Uh,
this was in 90,
this is right after the Russian mob thing.
So this is,
there was no digital cameras.
So it's real.
My,
I can tell you if you want somewhere out,
someone out there has an,
a dusty shoe box.
J coups motto that they brought back in is that photo you'll when til tickets.
They're Alpha brain PJ Cusumano um,
has,
has that picture.
I guarantee it because I know he's one of my,
one of my buddies,
it was on it with us.
He had one of those disposable cameras and came right up there like right up to
the stage and just snap.
Snap.
Cj,
if you're out there,
find me on Twitter.
What if it with PJ Stansberry the whole time for make it worth your while?
Pj for the comedy store?
Yeah.
So do you ever go to the best PJ face?
I've ever seen him.
Michael,
did you,
what'd you give him before the show?
So I have no idea.
I have.
I have no idea.
He's extra silly today.
[inaudible]
you ready to of course record?
Oh,
it is already.
What the fuck's on?